♪♪
Mike Gunton:
I remember I was standing on a
mountain with David Attenborough for the Africa series.
♪♪
Mike Gunton:
One of the lines he was saying
was, “Nowhere on the planet does wildlife put on a greater show.”
♪♪
Mike Gunton:
And I started thinking about,
“I wonder what it would have been like
to have stood here when the
Mike Gunton:
dinosaurs and those creatures
were at their finest moment.”
♪♪
And then I thought, “I wonder
if we could actually make a show
like that about dinosaurs.”
♪♪
(Roaring)
Mike Gunton:
It’s taken me 10 years to get
the right people together,
Mike Gunton:
to find the right stories,
to find the right environments to make it.
♪♪
Jon Favreau:
When the collaborating with Mike
Gunton came up,
Jon Favreau:
it would seemed like a fascinating
prospect.
♪♪
How could we show dinosaurs as
though we were filming them in
nature today?
♪♪
Mike Gunton:
We decided right up front
this would be real environments.
♪♪
Mike Gunton:
That’s influenced both the
stories we’ve told,
Mike Gunton:
the way we’ve told those
stories, the way we shot it
Mike Gunton:
the whole ethos of the series.
♪♪
Mike Gunton:
When you watch this show, what
you’re seeing in a way is just the tip of an iceberg.
♪♪
Mike Gunton:
Because we have got so many
people helping us on this,
experts of all types:
paleoclimatologists,
palaeobotanists,
paleo-ethnologists.
♪♪
Mike Gunton:
The amount of data that is
around at the moment is fascinating.
♪♪
What’s interesting here is how
surprising these behaviors are.
♪♪
Jon Favreau:
I think that’s part of the
filmmaking process,
Jon Favreau:
that you always have to keep the
audience interested
Jon Favreau:
by presenting them with things
they don’t expect.
♪♪
Jon Favreau:
We used the process that they
would’ve used for a documentary,
Jon Favreau:
which is sending a team out into
the field
♪♪
Jon Favreau:
to observe and to photograph an
environment at a certain place at a certain time.
♪♪
You just need to look around the
location I’m in now, and see the
elements that we’ve been facing.
♪♪
Simon Bell:
We are filming in places that
are inhospitable,
Simon Bell:
you know, places that are filled
with lava, with fire.
♪♪
Simon Bell:
You’re always looking for a
great shot,
and almost half-jokingly I, you
know, I invite the pilot,
you know, “can we-can we land
there?
Simon Bell:
A couple hundred meters away
from this volcano,"
Simon Bell:
you know, half-expecting for
him turn around to say,
Simon Bell:
“well there’s no way, that’s far
too dangerous.”
And then my excitement turned to
utter dread,
uh, when he started to, you know, dip the
nose of the helicopter down and
fly directly towards it.
♪♪
People might think, why bother
coming to such, you know,
challenging places to come and film?
Mike Gunton:
Why not create environments in
the computer?
Tim Walker:
The natural world is an
incredible place.
Trying to recreate that is a
great challenge.
Tim Walker:
If the opportunity’s there for
us to actually travel,
Tim Walker:
and capture in-camera the real
atmospherics the real lighting conditions,
Tim Walker:
it’s a far more satisfactory
situation
Tim Walker:
than trying to recreate the
natural world in a computer.
♪♪
Mother nature still delivers
when it comes to... comes to
this.
Mike Gunton:
It’s so hard to recreate in any
other way other than reality.
♪♪
Neil Harvey:
You know, we’re out here with
minimum kit,
no lights, no–not a great amount
of technology,
but sort of slightly, sort of
roughing it in, in the elements.
♪♪
Neil Harvey:
But we had to sort of
philosophically adopt a way of shooting this series.
Neil Harvey:
In a way, we imagined that we
would do if we were around this period.
♪♪
Neil Harvey:
Because one of the bespoke
ideas of a natural history wildlife documentary,
Neil Harvey
is the intimate portrayal of
those animals that we see.
♪♪
And that’s where we can bring
our skills as wildlife
filmmakers to bear.
Sam Bell:
You know, imagining if these
creatures were real, how would we film them?
Sam Bell:
Would we jump on ski-doos and
follow them?
Sam Bell:
Would we have the guts to walk
alongside them?
Sam Bell:
Would we be hiding in the
bushes?
And that sort of really informed
a lot of the decisions about,
you know, where we would be.
Quite often we would
deliberately place the camera
a long way away, behind some rocks,
Neil Harvey:
cause we’re thinking, “well, we
wouldn’t necessarily want to be noticed by these creatures,
Neil Harvey:
because that might effect their
behavior.”
Look over this way here.
-Yeah.
♪♪
We then do a round of shooting
where we film dinosaur cutouts,
Tim Walker:
to give the camera operators a
indication of where they need to be focusing.
♪♪
Mike Gunton:
The animals are portrayed quite
extraordinarily
Mike Gunton:
by the way that the artists have
created these creatures.
You, you look into their eyes
and you can see something’s
going on in these creatures’ heads.
♪♪
Jon Favreau:
When the final version of the
shot gets delivered,
and we finally get to see it
with everything incorporated.
♪♪
Jon Favreau:
There’s a magic experience that
you have, when you see it come to life.
Jon Favreau:
It looks like something you
would see in a nature documentary today.
♪♪
Jon Favreau:
And because, at the end of the
day,
Jon Favreau:
our scientists have the veto
power over anything we do
Jon Favreau:
if anything doesn’t pass
scientific muster, we rethink it.
Because we want this to be
scientifically authentic.
♪♪
Jon Favreau:
There are certain elements that
just make everything come together.
Jon Favreau:
In this landscape of so
many visual effects, and so much content,
Jon Favreau:
what made this one unique and
what we were going for,
Jon Favreau:
is what you feel when you watch
it.
♪♪
And I think when you get that
right, it makes you feel you’re
there.
♪♪